Now, what do you think? A man who
doesn't have the gift of celibacy,
what's going to happen to him?
So, it's hard, brethren.
Unless you have been gift given the gift
of celibacy, it's hell. That's why I'm
going to remind everyone of you, do not
make any of us superstars. I'm going to
sit in the kitchen for a minute. Do not
make any of us superstars.
No one on this side of glory is a
superstar. is immune from sin and
temptation. Why did I tell you? May God
destroy every form of idolatry and
blasphemy from us. May God guard my
heart not to be a fake. I try not to be
a fake, but there's only so much I can
say,
so much I can be upfront with.
Right? Because there are people who hate
me and don't want the best for me. They
want to see me destroyed. And may God
purify our hearts, our motives. Give us
the heart of the father, the heart of
the Lord Jesus Christ, the heart of the
Holy Spirit, not desire evil for anyone,
not be envious, may destroy my own envy
and jealousy, but at the same time not
to be fake and tolerate fake people. And
may God destroy the beams in our eyes
before we see the splinter in other
people's eyes. I say this because when I
tell you, I'm not saying this to be
humble. Believe me, last thing someone
can accuse me of is being humble.
humbleness in me, we're enemies.
Okay?
I say this because I know from what I
read in the Bible, I know from what I
see of people, I know from my own
failures and sins and struggles and
things I have done on this side of
glory, human beings
cannot be trusted. Human beings are
fickle. Human beings will be quick to
fall into sin.
Human beings will be quick to betray one
another and shame the Lord. I know this
from the stories I read in the Bible. I
see the characters in the Bible and how
they fell into major sin. And I've seen
it in the example of others around me
and in my own life. Things I've done
that I never thought I would do.
Well, Charlie, this is the problem.
Social media is a vehicle to be used to
glorify Jesus Christ because all my work
is online. If you can only go on social
media for growing in the faith, being
edified in the faith, and to learn your
faith and love the Lord Jesus Christ,
glory to God. Right?
So, when I say to you guys, you will be
disappointed if you idolize me. I'm
letting you know I'm uh listen unless
God protects me and reigns me in and the
Lord has mercy on me and pies me I will
fail the Lord. Not that I want to fail
the Lord. Understand? Do I want to fail
the Lord? No. Do I want to love Jesus
more than my life? Yes. Do I want to
glorify Jesus and die for Jesus? Yes. Do
I want my heart to belong to Jesus?
Absolutely. Do I want Jesus to be my
existence? Yes.
Yes, the Lord knows our hearts. Yes. But
I'm wicked. I'm weak. I'm not strong. If
I was strong, I wouldn't be struggling
with obesity and gluttony and I'm not.
All I'm trying to say is if you make us
more than we are
and you put your hope in us and when we
fail, your heart will be broken. But if
you see us as your brothers, sisters,
servants
who like you desperately need the blood
of Jesus, the flesh of Jesus, who are
sick and need the Holy Spirit to control
us and reign us in, then you will love
me and benefit from the gifts I have,
but you will pray for me and cry out to
the Lord that not only you, but I won't
fail. But once you idolize this, it's
over.
Once you idolize this, it's over.
Once you make us an idol, it's over.
Right? And I'm mentioning this because I
have to tread lightly because I know
everyone is talking about this recent
scandal. You guys have heard of it,
right? As I said, I'll talk about it,
but I have to do it reverently because
he came out and made a statement.
Made a statement. So, I want to talk
about if you're okay with me talking
about it. And I got to be careful what I
say. May God destroy the beams in my
eyes. Even this young lady, I told her,
"It's why by the grace of God, we need
to ask the Lord to make it clear what
his will is for us and to protect you
and guard you and me to fight it and the
Lord have mercy on us."
Why? Because if the Lord has something
better for her, I pray God releases her.
But if the Lord wants me to be Christ to
her, to do something where it happens,
but again, I have my daughters, they
don't want me to get married, and she
has a daughter.
Right? She's a good woman, loves the
Lord, but she's a woman and I'm a man
and we're flesh. And here's another
advice for all of you men. The longer
you're with someone, let me tell you
from experience, my own and others,
okay, let me give you advice. The longer
you are with that partner you want to
marry and the longer you delay marriage,
the harder it will be to resist and
you'll succumb to fornication.
Just letting you know you don't believe
me. Go to your priest and say, "Father,
how many godly Catholics who love the
Lord who want to stay pure struggle with
fornication because they're together and
waiting to get married? They don't blink
an eye." So meaning if you have someone,
especially someone local, and you know
that's the one, don't delay it. I'm
letting you know the longer you delay
it, the more you're going to be tempted
in sin. Just a fact, man. It's just a
fact.
Yeah, Michael. Only the someone who is a
monk who's called to celibacy won't
fall. Let's be honest. But that's the
whole point. It's not an excuse. It's
not an excuse, right? Yeah. Get rid of
the dogs. Uh divine divine. So, that's
my advice from my experience. But let me
explain to you why I'm mentioning it. I
got to tread lightly, man. Seeing these
images and the Palestinians is killing
me, man. It It is killing me.
I don't want to see this. All right. I'm
going to be very careful because he made
a statement. So, I'm going to go and
look at a statement.
All right?
And I'm not one to sit in judgment. May
God destroy the beams in our eyes. But
there's one thing and it's not an excuse
but I have to make it clear what I'm
saying. One thing if you have someone
you love and this person that you love
you are striving to get married and you
struggle to stay pure. It's another
thing when you go around,
right,
go around
and trying to then
engage in immoral behavior with a group
of women and keep it hidden from one
another from from the other women.
That's one thing. Here, let me give you
example again here. Watch here, guys.
No, I'm not gonna I don't want to poison
your eyes. You see on Instagram. Okay,
let me talk about the recent scandal
that came up. And I got to be very
careful how I say it. So, we're going to
go to his channel.
Now, I have some information from
reliable sources that are in the know
and they have receipts, but I can't
mention their names. So, I'm not going
to mention names, but I'm going to share
some with you. I'm just going to do it.
And I pray God have mercy on us and on
me. And I speak carefully cuz it's
everyone's talking about it. Even JP
had to jump on it.
Everyone's talking about it. Everyone's
not making this the news. You know what
I'm talking about, right?
Everyone is talking about it. Christian
Wagner is talking about it. Avoiding
Babylon's talking about it. JP is
talking about it. Idolkiller is talking
about it.
Alex
is now the focus of all attention.
He's now getting all attention for all
the wrong reasons.
Everyone's talking about it here. It's
Christian Wagner.
A series of texts were
published
and a photo of him
where he is engaging
in less than appropriate behavior and
language with a girl who he was
catechizing. He was her catechist
and it is stated she was between 15 and
16 years old. Now here he says that
people are saying she's 14. He goes
that's a lie. But it's not just her.
There are texts that have been submitted
that he's been doing this with many
women even as recently as June. And
there are voice texts. I'm just letting
you know inside story. I know this from
a very reliable source.
And these texts and voice texts have
been submitted to a particular
source and they have the receipts. So
it's not just based on rumors.
Okay? Not just based on rumors.
Now even in this statement he doesn't
deny his sin. He denies that the girl
was 14. Even here
I want I want to read it for you. I want
you to read and understand carefully
exactly divine orthodox orthodoxia
right here. I must address the
accusations that have been circling
online over the last 24 hours. First and
foremost, the accusation I was having in
relation with a 14-y old girl is a
complete fabrication. Yes, there may
have been some who said 14. Actually,
one of the sources told me it's 15 or
16. All right, but the messages are
there. So what is he denying that she's
14? But I want you to see. I am treating
an accusation of magnitude with the
seriousness that it deserves. I've made
my church aware of what is being said
about me online and we have contacted
the authorities. I'm voluntarily
cooperating in an investigation.
Good. Well, that's what Michael Brown
others did and didn't come out looking
good for Brown and others that will
allow the truth to come to light and
that will dispel this awful and vicious
rumor. Now notice the only awful vicious
rumors of the 14-year-old. Did you catch
it? I want you to be smart when you
read.
That's what he is adamant against.
But now watch. I'm also prepared to
undergo legal action against those who
defame me. But here's where he basically
admits the guilt to and the seriousness
to all the other things. I must also
sincerely apologize everyone who has
been hurt, shocked, scandalized by these
room. It is of great importance that I
also acknowledge all of my mistakes,
failures, and sins. I'm a wretched
sinner. That's confession right there.
Was in desperate need of God's mercy as
well as in need of the forgiveness of
those whom I offend and sin against. He
just acknowledged it's not a lie.
Do you understand?
The only thing he's adamant against is
that there was a 14-year-old that he had
inappropriate behavior with. But he's
not denying the sex thing.
because there is actual evidence and
there is voice text and one is pretty
bad. One is actually very bad. And I say
nothing until they bring out bring it to
like very bad. And from what I was told,
there's also
voice text texting up until June.
So you see that
everyone caught it, right?
He this right here is a tacid admission.
He has sinned.
Now I understand. Look, there is no
justification. May God forgive me if I
sound like justif. If you have a young
lady you love and you want to marry and
you struggle with sexual purity,
fornication, and you're trying to go to
the priest and confess and fight until
you get married, I understand that.
That's common. It's not right. But this
is not what he's being accused of.
You understand?
You understand the point, guys?
So, what's
the point? When you idolize me or
William or Michael Loftton, you're going
to be crushed and disappointed. This can
happen to me.
Do Am I afraid it can happen to me? Yes,
I am afraid. Why? because I'm not a
Superman. I'm not Superman. I'm not
super spiritual. I'm not holier than
thou. It can't happen to me. The
temptation is real. The attacks are real
on all who are in the limelight cuz
Satan wants to take us out. So, if
you're not praying for William or myself
and others, the spirit save us from our
own flesh, then it's over for us. But my
point being is,
my point being,
you have to not make any human figure on
this side of glory an idol.
On this side of glory, you can't make
any figure an idol. May God destroy all
idolatry. You want to look to figures to
emulate,
look to the saints who have finished the
race. They can't sin anymore. Look to
the holy martyrs, the theologians, the
fathers,
the doctors of the church who finished
the race. They can't sin anymore.
Right? St. Teresa can't sin anymore. St.
Padre Peio can't sin anymore. Right? St.
Kalamos can't sin anymore. St. Moses the
Black can't sin anymore. Paul can't sin
anymore. Our queen, our mother was kept
pure. she's glorified. She won't sin.
When you finish the race and you die in
unichrist, then you look to that person.
But as long as we have breath, we can
fail. And I'm letting you know, I fear
for myself. I'm not lying. I fear for
myself. The young lady will tell you,
right?
So do not idolize us. Don't look to
those who finish the race. Popes can
disappoint you, right? So, Catholics,
how many points have how many popes have
turned into antipes?
How many popes were antipopes?
You cannot look and idolize
any human on this side of glory. Number
one, you can't have idols and you cannot
deify men in your hearts.
So then look to those who finish the
race. St. Paul, pray for us. St. Jerome,
pray for us. St. Athtonius, pray for us.
St. Sirill, pray for us. Look to them.
They can't fail. They finished the race.
They're resting. They're perfected.
They're sinless.
You with me there? So, if one thing I
want to hammer, please, if you love me,
don't idolize me and pray for me. I
daily cry out to God to save me from the
demons. If you guys know my demons, the
lust I struggle with, the
bitterness from losing my my daughters,
the struggle with lazy and slot food. I
am a mess and I'm sick and I know my
Jesus, my Lord, loves me and I beg him,
save me, Lord, and don't let me get
puffed up because I can get puffed up
besides getting fat.
So please, brethren, don't idolize us,
please. and see me as another sick
member of the body who desperately needs
to be healed. And I need your prayers. I
need your prayers. Who's calling me now?
Come on, man.
All right. I need your prayers. In point
of fact,
I I think if people who know me and meet
me, they'll tell you
I don't know. I don't want to sound like
American, but people know me. The last
thing you'll get being with me is that I
think I'm holy and I'm a saint. That's
the last thing you're gonna get. The
first thing you're gonna get is this
guy's weird. He's got mental issues.
He's a goofball. Is either serious
talking about faith or he's joking.
There is no in between because I got
mental issues, man.
So, keep that in mind, right? Keep that
in mind. So
sadly, I don't think it's going to end
well for Alex because you just saw he
basically confessed he has sinned. He
has done what these women have come out
and said he's done. His only concern is
not to be accused of doing something a
14-year-old because that means he'll
spend some jail time. That's his fear.
If there's a rumor he did something
inappropriate with a 14-year-old, she's
underage. He's afraid of the backlash,
the criminal charges, right? So that's
what he's passionately denying. But the
rest of things he did not deny, right?
So
Alex
by the grace of God just needs to step
away. May God forgive us. Forgive me.
Just step away, brother. Because there
is no coming back from this. Even if the
rumors are false,
men are not like God. God is not like
man. Men will not forgive. They will
always always always condemn you. Right.
So pretty much it's it happened with
Michael Brown. Just let you know. Yeah,
it is. Mango, it's over. It happened
with Michael Brown. What do I mean?
This is where I'm going to show you a
passage of scripture. Okay. It happened
to Michael Brown. Okay. Michael Brown,
I think it's over 20 years ago, there
was a sex a secretary and he had an
emotional attachment to her. Didn't have
sex with her. There was some
inappropriate behavior. No sex. He got
convicted. He confessed, told his wife,
it was resolved. He was forgiven. Okay,
he's forgiven. Fast forward 20 years
later, the woman comes back and makes it
an issue and goes public and then
Michael Brown's friends became his
enemies, his detractors,
and they did an investigation,
you know, an independent investigation.
They go, "Yeah, this happened." But he
acknowledged it happened. He
acknowledged it. He acknowledged it back
then. He told his wife he he asked for
forgiveness. Forgive him. Move on. No,
they don't move on. So that was 20 years
ago.
They don't move on. They make it
something
for him to deal with. Now, now some of
the people who supposedly his friends
turn against him, accuse him being a
narcissist, tell him step down. And this
is where I'm getting disgusted. Okay,
brethren.
He did this over 20 years ago. Thank God
he didn't have sex with her. It was bad
that he was flirting with her. He
acknowledged it. He went public with his
ministry, with his wife. He asked for
forgiveness of the woman. He was
forgiven. That's it. And he's been clean
ever since. So when do we say as
Christians, your sins have been
forgiven? They've been removed. You've
moved on. Put it in the past. Now let's
move forward because the way these
hypocritical Pharisees act towards
Christians who've made mistakes 20 years
ago that they have acknowledged and they
confessed and they were forgiven. The
way they act that means David should
have never never remained the king.
David his book should be removed from
the Bible. Solomon, his book should be
removed from the Bible because if you do
to the prophets what they're doing to
these men, David murdered a man after
committing adultery at his wife.
When God confronted him, he repented.
God exposed his sin, shamed him, brought
this one in his household, but he did
not remove him from being king. Nor did
he remove his books. Same with Solomon.
So when do we realize all right forgiven
forgotten the man has shown true
repentance he's accepted responsibility
and he's become a better Christian now
and more on fire for the Lord that's
passed when do we then have that
attitude
it's as if that's it over
when I want to know help me out because
if you do to the prophets what these
guys do to people you're gonna have to
remove the books of David, the Proverbs
of Solomon,
and other writings because there's a
time for forgiveness and forgetting and
moving on.
You with me there?
You You know what I'm saying? God,
purify my heart. Grant me the heart of
Jesus. I try not to be a hypocrite,
right? But come on,
it's time to move on. But you know what?
Human beings, they're wicked. It is in
our flesh. We want to see
someone else getting destroyed. We love
it when we see human being getting beat
up or destroyed because we're wicked and
FL you but not me. And Michael Brown's
ministry has never been the same since.
It's never been the same since. I got to
shave my head.
His ministry has not been the same. Go
watch it. In fact, Sean McDow removed
the interview he did with Michael Brown
from his YouTube channel.
Okay. Is this biblical Christian? Help
me understand. Say, I got a shave.
Is this biblical Christianity?
I want to know. Should we not allow
room? All right. Michael Brown has
proven himself a man of integrity. It's
been over 20 years. Never fall into that
sin. He's been on fire for the Lord. a
man of integrity. And thank God it
didn't cross the boundaries of adultery.
That's 20 years ago. Let the man move
forward for the kingdom of God. A man
who's destroying rabbitic Judaism. A man
who LGBTQ,
right, same-sex marriages, a man who's
been doing great work and showing Jews
Jesus is Messiah, God is triune, and
that this lifestyle is an abomination.
He was at the forefront,
but Satan wants to erase him because
he's a danger.
Okay.